in sync reunites as the boys get their
star on the Walk of Fame the day has
finally arrived in sync together again I
cannot get any of their songs out of my
head because today is NSYNC day guys
Justin JC Lance Joey and Chris all the
guys reunited to get their star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and I've been to
many of these Walk of Fame ceremonies
but I have never seen anything like this
before
fans started lining up around 3:00 a.m.
this morning and check this out the
thousands of in sinkers stretches for
miles just to get a glimpse of the
fellas and can you blame them this is
the first time all five guys have been
together since they performed at the
VMAs and 2013 and et of course was in
the middle of all the madness
[Music]
this is so surreal you guys are the best
fans in the world
Justin giving a shout out to the fans
from near and far also thanked his wife
jessica biel who is in the audience I
just love all of you so much and so
don't touch me
fans were screaming reunion reunion
reunion is there a possibility of an
ensign green in the future what do you
think this is today
Joey JC Chris Justin we're brothers
we're family and out of all this the
Busic the tour's love from the fans
it's my Brotherhood with you guys that
I'm most thankful for I'll see them all
like that together has me so hype are
you guys feeling the nostalgia - and by
the way how fitting they're getting
their start on April 30th because as we
know tomorrow I just have to I'm sorry
that I'm not sorry all right if that
doesn't fill your heart with in-seat
nostalgia maybe this will the
celebration of the 20th anniversary of
NSYNC and the band getting their star
there's an extra special treat for the
diehard fans in Los Angeles the dirty
pop up shop filled with all kinds of
instant goodies and that only our Lauren
Zima got a special tour of the pop up
from JC Chao save yourself this one is
something that Justin wore Cobra reveal
dangerous some of us keep more than
others Joey happens to be a pack rat
some of the stuff is just all fresh
never seen before you had one outfit
that you're like me why did I worry
about we got a bedroom set up here
because who didn't have an insane poster
we imagined we thought it would be cold
when we were thinking about something we
thought about being somebody young and a
fan of ours that would you know play the
tunes and practice the dance routines in
front of their mirror
this is probably the first time I've
been in something like this since the
it's gonna be May video it's gonna bang
mag being here gotta ask you one more
time like could we ever get a reunion
tour God look there are no talks about a
reunion tour right now you get like cool
merch for right now and then you know
the future is what it is you know no one
can predict the future
sorry guys unless JC is playing coy
we're gonna have to settle for the Walk
of Fame ceremony being the only reunion
we get for now at least all right we've
got plenty more with NSYNC over at et
online.com and of course ET has been
with the band since the beginning we've
got a special look back at the first
time we met in sync that will be up on
ETS YouTube channel there's also a
playlist there but the first time we met
Ryan Gosling Selena Gomez Taylor Swift
and Miley Cyrus you can binge them all
there thanks for watching guys happy
insync day I'm out
[Music]